foreign
starts off this hour in Minneapolis hi
Marley how are you
I am good thank you good how can we help
uh I am calling to get some advice on
how we stop doing too many baby steps at
once while in the middle of building a
house
okay how many are you doing
um well we are attempting to pay off
debt have a savings fund and then also
have over 20 percent
of equity in our homes which we've
already gotten that one
now we're realizing we're just we're
starting in the middle of doing the baby
steps and we need to take a step back so
so the house is under construction
correct and you're under contract for it
yep okay yep so we are building it
ourselves which is how we've gotten
um our Equity with it
okay
so that decision is done
yeah can't really undo it
okay so let's just set that aside and
you've got 20 percent
Equity because of the Sweat Equity or
you've got the actual cash
um a mix of both we've paid
um quite a bit out of pocket already
um then plus the flood Equity so we will
have well over 20 okay what do you need
to finish the house in cash
to finish the house in cash the what
cash do you need to finish this project
that you've started
um we would need 400 000.
so that's what our mortgage will end up
being when we are done that's your
mortgage is not cash your mortgage is
borrowed money I'm talking about how
much money do you need in the bank
to finish this project
thank you
um we
were having a lot of cash flow coming in
and out but we're taking drugs
beforehand so really that's all being
done with the bank team for the
um expenses as they're coming
so you have a construction loan
correct yeah okay in addition to the
construction loan do you have any cash
needs
um no the house
yeah okay so if you took no cash out of
your budget you can finish the house
with the construction loan and get your
permanent mortgage correct
correct okay that's what I was trying to
get at so then that project now we can
kind of seal the wall on that no no pun
intended and push that to the side
that's taken care of now let's go work
the baby steps
okay
so what is your income
120 girls all right and how much debt do
you have
not counting the house
62.
all right what kind of debt is the 62
made up of
50 000 in vehicles in 12 000 in college
what are the vehicles
um we have two of them
um one is majority of it
um
and that is a Chevy Tahoe and then a
Honda Civic now what do you owe on the
Tahoe
40 000. okay
if I woke up in your shoes I'd sell the
Tahoe I'd amputate the Tahoe
okay you call me because you're stressed
out freaked out and you got money going
out 14 different directions and you
can't breathe
and you're driving a freaking forty
thousand dollar truck while you're
trying to build a house in the middle of
it
yep
I would want my life back more than I
wanted the Tahoe
okay if I were you you're pretty easy on
this is it it's your car isn't it
yes yeah it is ours it's just convincing
my husband to do that has been the
um what's his problem he loves the
stress
in the hole if we get rid of it and well
you're already in the hole when you get
rid of it you just admit it
yeah yeah he thinks paying it off and
then having it for until it runs into
the ground is that would have been a
good idea if you did that before you
built a house
that that would have helped yes because
right now you guys have nothing in
savings because you need it all
um yeah well nothing that we could throw
at any of the debt right now other than
we have extra cash flow each month and
so we've been throwing that at our house
right now it's like I thought the
construction almost covering the house
yeah we've just been trying to pay as
much cash as possible and now meanwhile
you're driving a forty thousand dollar
Tahoe
doing that and that too yeah this is
bass backwards kiddo you guys got to
clean this debt up and you gotta you've
got the dead gum uh cash set up to do
the construct with the construction loan
to finish the house just finish the
house with the debt you've already
committed to that that's a whole You've
dug you're set for that that's a done
deal and it's not completely out of
control it's just out of order
and so it's not the end of the world uh
and then I would look up and say if I
can't get these cars and this sixty
thousand dollars paid off in less than a
year I'm dumping this Tahoe and I'm
probably just dumping it it just doesn't
fit in this equation
because here's the thing your husband
does not feel the risk that you all are
carrying and you feel it
yeah
it's really bothering you and he's
walking along whistling through the
woods and a bear is getting ready to
kill him
and you know there's bears and for some
reason he's unaware there's a bear
you follow me
yeah yeah so you need to grab him by his
face with your two hands put the kids to
bed turn off the television put the
screens down and look in him in the eyes
and say I am so scared I can't breathe
you're killing me
okay because that's the truth isn't it
yeah and he he honestly he honestly
listen I know you know how I know this
guy I'm him
I did this exact same crap to my wife in
my 20s
because I don't have a risk meter
I just go do crap and if it's wrong I'll
go do something else
and that's him okay and he's just he's
whistling along in the middle of that
gum Bear Country here and he's
attracting Grizzlies and doesn't even
know what they look like and his wife is
actually smart and she's going this is
scary and my wife was doing the exact
same thing I about about ran her in the
ditch man I about killed her so I'm
telling you I'm I'm begging him as the
old guy who made the same mistakes he
did to listen to his wife who can find a
virtuous wife her worth is far above
rubies the heart of her husband safely
trusts her and he will have
No Lack of gain
wow
listen to your wife man Timeless wisdom
if she's virtuous listen to her if she's
a princess that's different but if she's
virtuous you need to listen to her she's
probably smarter than you are and in
this case that's true the case of Dave
and the case of Marley's husband yeah no
question this isn't a Dave Ramsey said
we have to sell the Tahoe this is I'm so
scared we have to do something drastic
yeah to get to say because you run
around chasing your tail is not making
me happy